we all share that one fantasy pay off
all that credit card debt and go to bed
snug between the covers of financial
security something like that right
well the lottery is one way that
millions of Americans hope their bank
balance struggles can be eased after all
something like 1.5 billion dollars can
go a long way but what are we paying for
when we buy those tickets
well States get a percentage of the
lotto sales which they often promise to
give to chronically underfunded schools
which sounds like good news
but the reality isn't as great as that
promise lotteries are a painless way for
politicians to raise money for the
government you buy a lotto ticket and
the money goes towards public education
no one gets mad about raising taxes and
the school gets money or at least that's
how it's supposed to work but in a lot
of states lottery tickets aren't really
helping schools that much take
California for example where lottery
revenue is less than 2% of education
spending the state has a 76 billion
dollar education budget and only about
1.4 billion of that is from the lottery
there's also North Carolina where the
lottery brings in more than 500 million
dollars a year but that doesn't mean
there's more money for schools since the
lottery started ten years ago North
Carolina actually spends less on
education than it did before and then
there's the issue of who is buying the
tickets Americans spent a whopping
seventy billion dollars on lotteries in
2014 that's more than we spent on sports
tickets books video games movies and
music combined advertisements for state
lotteries promised that winning the
lottery can help you achieve your dreams
things like paying for college buying a
home or getting out of that job but that
promise plays into financial and
securities so while upper income
Americans tend to play the lottery for
fun when the jackpot gets really big
people who are lower-income play lottery
tickets more often as a kind of
investment in their future in South
Carolina for instance fifty-four percent
of lottery players earned less than 40
thousand dollars a year this in effect
makes lotteries a regressive tax because
its revenue for the state that sucks up
a disproportionate amount of low income
people salaries and spending that money
on lotto tickets has a different
financial effect on someone making
$40,000 a year versus someone who's
making $75,000 a year and that brings us
back to how state governments sell the
lottery they know that the hope of
financial stability is a powerful
incentive to play so the lottery is a
fun way to possibly win lots of cash but
it's also a tax on the country's most
underprivileged that doesn't come close
to delivering on the promise of better
funded schools but with so much money up
for grabs
it doesn't hurt to buy a ticket and
remember if you win don't take the lump
sum